this is Startalk we have flying cars
today
they're called helicopters yeah and
they're really noisy yeah and in fact if
you want something as heavy as a car to
levitate you're gonna be making some
noise well it's also gonna use a lot of
energy and a lot of energy
well that's because in the word of a
another physicist I know who flies his
own plane he said helicopters don't fly
as much as they beat the air into
submission
who said that's it's true that's all
it's completely there the air doesn't
submit it just flows down having enough
momentum to hold the helicopter up the
other thing about tunnels is we have
that technology here in New York City we
have the technology to a limited extent
in Boston and Washington to a very
limited extent in Los Angeles and
somewhat in Seattle this technology
exists you go to Minneapolis no tunnels
but they have those skyways oh yeah you
can walk all around downtown it's an ant
farm yeah yeah they don't they don't
want to admit that comes up it's right
that's a Habitrail habit right it's a
human habit River there's my cosmos
Skyway there you gotta give a sexy name
no you are a frickin ant in a tube well
whereas in the subway platform you go
WOW I'm no but but termites and ants are
not lying at our Subway's jealous of it
if you look at the skyways in these
tubes connecting buildings it looks just
like the Habitrail that you get at a pet
shop the other thing is that they're
attractive to me they're attractive
he also Elon Musk brings up another good
point what when we have humans operating
the toy sonic flying car which you can
have at the Chinese subterranean vehicle
pee who's going to drive the thing
without all kinds of trouble and so you
know it always fascinates me when you
look at highways from the air when
you're in an airplane or a helicopter
it looks so orderly yeah it really does
cars all they merge that go along very
cool but you're using a human brain this
thing is capable of our
ten radio shows and and rocket companies
you're using this brain to do nothing
but operate this car on this
right-of-way stay in a straight line
stay in the street stage injuries let's
go over your shoulder look ahead Chuck
head check whoa whoa head check and so
this is why this seems like a real
opportunity but my favorite bumper
stickers every caution driver applying
makeup I've seen it
I see you've seen behind me no so you
don't you don't you don't want humans
driving cards you want driverless cars
yeah that a very high level reliability
now you know I used to work at Boeing
and you get a triple we worked on the
747 747 a little bit seven to seven
three seven five seven but yeah what you
want is lingo Chuck right now well
that's how you
he's showing that off now sound like
giving me your number these are all
planes everywhere from Boeing has a
seven seven seven seven in it yeah well
yeah but when it's triple redundant
autopilot you can count on it it's going
to land the plane that's e us but the
problem with cars is not you don't have
nearly the traffic control that you that
you have in in airplanes so who's gonna
win this history ins cross the street in
front of you and who do you think's
going to win this Tesla and with a
driverless car perhaps coming out of the
air shop or Google well Tesla makes cars
Google makes software you can't have one
without the other to be Lewis so this is
like a chocolate and peanut butter thing
exactly whoa you got your car in line
the software got your sucker in my car
but wait there you're both wrong I love
setting you up but wait but wait there's
more when you think about the automotive
industry writ large everybody uses the
same parts mmm what the gas gauge sensor
the speedometer your tires the nuts all
the sit bolt Saul the same standard
there's a little competition but you can
get a lot of commonality and so we will
see what happens in the near future this
is Startalk